bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors on l'a dit
le dollar connaît une baisse de sa
valeur depuis le début de la crise du
coronavirus la pandémie est elle la
seule explication de cette situation
alors la question est pertinente est
évidemment assez logique mais avant d'y
répondre ce serait important de remettre
un petit peu en perspective la posture
du dollar est un peu plus sur la durée
notamment par rapport à des records
qu'on a pu connaître il ya bien
longtemps
donc déjà aujourd'hui avec un dollar à
1,18 19
on est loin des records de 82 cents pour
1 euro en octobre 2000 ou 1,6
dollars en juillet 2008 et depuis on est
plutôt entre 1,1 et 1,2 dollar pour un
euro
donc globalement on est encore dans un
périmètre eurusd vu e rue mais dans un
contexte durable de change plutôt fixe
entre devises occidentales occidentales
se retrouver sur une baisse du dollar de
5% sur le seul mois de juillet pour être
le symptôme des faits plus graves pour
les us alors pourquoi donc tout d'abord
l'europe à elle plutôt suivi le coc vide
aussi mais d'une manière peut être géré
de manière plus efficace donc de
meilleurs absolument pour dire que le
roi perdu de sa force puisque c'est sous
jacents sont dégradées lui aussi mais
pourtant le dollar arrive à perdre
encore plus alors ça traduit quoi à
l'entrée et des craintes sur un retour
d'inflation peut-être mer plus triviale
sa marque le sentiment des cambistes à
ne pas avoir de visibilité sur la santé
des us donc ok il ya le coc vide mais
comment on va sortir l'économie de la
crise qu vide
quelle masse monétaire va-t-il falloir
injecter dans l'économie
quelle sera la politique du prochain
président américain
il est aussi la chine qui manifestent de
plus en plus son envie de s'affranchir
du dollar comme monnaie de référence du
commerce mondial est ce qu'on peut
assister à un événement du wan ou d'une
autre monnaie dans un futur proche c'est
ce que c'est faisable
concrètement alors s'affranchir du
dollar les chinois c'est quelque chose
qu'ils ont mis en oeuvre quasiment
depuis la crise des subprimes en 2008
puisque il devenait une quantité extrême
de bons du trésor est considéré qu'ils
se retrouvaient en risque en possédant
ces bons du trésor pour autant il ne
pouvait pas de suite
les reventes parce que cela aurait été
extrêmement néfaste pour eux donc depuis
à peu près une dizaine d'années ils sont
en ordre de marche pour petit à petit
liquider les actifs qu'ils ont vis-à-vis
des us et en parallèle le yuan chinois
lui va plutôt avoir une posture à ce
qu'on gagne à se renforcer par rapport à
des actifs tels que l'or par exemple je
vous interromps je parle et vous parlez
je me permets de vous interrompre vous
parlez de l'or
justement lors elle habite quand même
connaissent ont connu une hausse de leur
valeur ces derniers mois est ce qu'on
est en train d'assister finalement à une
modification du comportement des
investisseurs sur l'or c'est pas nouveau
je suis le bitcoin là il faut faire
juste un petit focus aujourd'hui profite
mécaniquement de la baisse du dollar
pour marquer sa propre os mais selon moi
ça ne traduit rien sur la solidité du 2
du dollar futur par exemple aujourd'hui
le bitcoin ne fait que revenir sur un
niveau il ya un an environ on était déjà
à onze mille dollars
donc on est loin des records de fin 2007
sur bitcoin on doit comprendre que son
cours est plutôt lié à des mouvements ou
des infos de la culture ce faire elle
même et non reliées à un contexte
économico géopolitique dans le cas
présent sont plutôt les bonnes nouvelles
de l'arrivée imminente des thés rome 2
et les manoeuvres de quelques grands
détenteurs de btc les fameuses baleines
et qui ont formé ce mouvement fortement
haussier spécifiquement le 27 juillet
rapidement une dernière question je me
permet encore de vous interrompre on a
le temps qu'ils qui passent leur eau
dans tout ça parce qu'on parle beaucoup
du dollar on parle du human mais qu'elle
est dans quel état se trouve l'euro en
fait le roi évidemment suivi une
dégradation un petit peu du du même
ordre que le dollar notamment liée au
contexte
actuel économique qu i de tension etc
mais on peut quand même constater que
globalement la zone euro c'est mieux mis
en ordre de marche déjà sur le plan
sanitaire et
sur le plan de la gestion de la crise
économique qui est en train de d'émerger
et puis aussi sur le plan politique
globalement on a réussi à peu près à
s'entendre et là ce sont des points
vraiment en décalage par rapport aux us
et ça se traduit justement par la force
de la monnaie donc oui lors de manière
absolue a perdu de sa valeur et
d'ailleurs on le voit par l'euro a perdu
de sa valeur par rapport à l'or je veux
dire et on le voit par rapport à l'or
qui lui est plutôt une matière
relativement plate en fait si on repère
par rapport des valeurs de la vie
courante
donc oui l'euro a perdu de la valeur
mais le dollar en a perdu
encore plus finalement même aujourd'hui
cette force de l'or est assez
particulière parce que c'est quasiment
une matière qui est en train de se re
monétiser puisqu'on voit qu'elle est en
ce moment un petit peu abandonné de
l'industrie ou de la chaîne surtout de
l'achat de bijoux parce que il devient
très cher et par contre seront monétise
en devenant une matière achetés par les
banques centrales voire utilisé dans
certains dans certaines transactions
soit pour couvrir ou au pays des dettes
pour preuve trois cent mille et trois de
droite 33 mille tonnes d'or sont
aujourd'hui détenus dans les banques
centrales contre un total de 200 mille
tonnes d'or accessible par les humains
au sens large d'envoyer l'or n'est pas
qu'une matière première c'est une quasi
monnet jean-françois fort merci
infiniment pour toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste des
monnaies président fondateur du groupe
aucoffre.com merci à vous